So I want to welcome you to today's fun topic, which is suffering and sacrifice. And it's related to the dark night of the soul.
So a special point in time and experience that all human beings know and that Jung talked about because they saw a really fundamental function of psychological experience and psychological development. And first we have to think about why do we suffer? What is happening here?
And I'm starting with a quote. And you always have emotions where you are not adapted. If you are adapted, you need no emotion. An emotion is only an instinctive explosion, which denotes that you have not been up to your task. When you don't know how to deal with a situation or with people, You get emotional since you are not adapted. You had the wrong idea of the situation.
So this is a concept that not a lot of people know about, but Jung talked about, which is that of adaptation. And he sees us with our consciousness being adapted to the world. This can be the outside world as we are right now sitting in front of a laptop in a house or apartment, interacting with a lot of things outside. But also the inner world.
So our psychology, our thoughts, dreams, yeah, and emotions and affects also. And he sees there a development taking place that we kind of always try to approximate our reality and our circumstances to act in them. So we start out as small children.
Incapable of really doing things for ourselves, being very dependent on other people to do things for us, and developing into self-reliant beings and adults, ideally. And if one wants to see suffering, it's very easy to see with children when they want something and they cannot get it, or they get hurt when they do something. This is already a lot of emotion, a lot of suffering.
And Jung sees there already a kind of psychological function that this is a feedback, a kind of feedback system that tells us the things are not as we are expecting them to be and getting then our attention, getting our focus. He even says that if you want someone to become conscious, the best way is to hit them on the head.
This really gets their attention. So he says consciousness is there to adapt and to adjust, which means it's used in emergency situations, in situations that are problematic, that are difficult, and where a need for development is necessary. So everything that seems, let's say, negative is an opportunity to grow.
And Jung says this is what consciousness does, but of course also does not really like to do. Because it is incredibly stressful and it is a big change in the psychology of the psyche. And this is what this event will be about. So yeah, you want to do something, it fails. You hit your head, you become aware, but you also become emotional.
You have suddenly strong emotions coming up. This can be anger. This can be fear. That can be sadness. Or also pain. And I guess everyone is familiar with all these phenomena that then arise. But Jung says, and this is the cool part, we can adapt to that. We can change to that.
But already being aware that, let's say, having some strong affects or emotions is already a kind of moral development. This is already a sign of like a very aware consciousness to say, okay, yeah, it's not flying off the handle every time when something does not go my way.
It's not a good way. It means you're not really adapted and there is room for improvement there to grow. So We hit our head, we did not get what we want or what we expected, or horrible things are happening. The next stage is suffering, and I have here three quotes for that. So, suffering is the indispensable part.
Any real solution is only found through intense suffering. And also, so long as human beings are insufficiently domesticated, they suffer. That is from barbaric lack of self-control. They without fail fall prey to pairs of opposites. And lastly, behind the neurosis, there's often concealed all the natural and necessary suffering the patient has been unwilling to bear.
So I want to go into all of those quotes. So the first one, suffering is an indispensable part. This is where Jung sees The dilemma of existing. We are limited beings in an unlimited universe. So the things we want to do likely don't work and we don't know how to do.
So we suffer for that. Just the existence creates problems.
And the really interesting part that I realized in my working life is There's sometimes problems at work that seem absolutely unsolvable and incredibly tall and overtowering.
But if you really push through them and you stick with them and you suffer through them, in the end it works out. But it seems like there is like a minimum amount of suffering and time necessary just for things to turn out well. But it is that. So this is, we, we have a problem. We are in a situation we did not predict or something we did not want.
And this is when consciousness becomes active. And this is when looking for a solution, paying attention, working out problems happens. So Jung sees that really as a conscious function, as something that consciousness needs to do.
In contrast, for example, to unconscious, that is more receptive and is able to provide possible solution if consciousness is willing to listen. So it becomes a dialogue within the psyche. And the second quote goes into the same direction.
So if our consciousness is not able to deal with the world and with ourselves, it will remind us that we are missing certain things. And this is what you teach children. Oh, you cannot have this now. You have to wait. You cannot always scream and shout if you want something. And some people stop when they grow up and some people don't stop when they do that.
So this is a necessary precondition of life and things happening and us existing in a world that there's this constant readaption to situations that are new to us, that are difficult for us, and somehow always something is happening.
But, and this is what the third quote is about, not every suffering is the same. So people can also suffer unnecessarily. And there he uses a word which is neurosis.
And what Carl Gustav Jung understands as neurosis is a psychological problem that you have in your psyche complexes. So autonomous unconscious forces who, let's say, make your life difficult.
So a complex behavior is, for example, when people misspeak, misremember, get strange and foreign ideas, have accidents, for example, because they're unconcentrated. So that psyche is divided in a sense. There are things in the psyche that are messing around and making things more complicated.
Somebody wants to do something, but it's somehow these gremlins in the background of the mind that create problems. And Jung, being a very positive person, said in these complexes, in these psychological troubles that come up, is also the potentiality for future development.
So he sees neurosis, which is another word for depression, as something positive, as a reaction of the psyche trying to create a new balance. Us with our consciousness doing things, we become adapted to certain things that are there, but that does not mean that these are all the things that exist.
So when you are only, let's say, in your family circle, As a child, this works out fine, but you need to go find a friend group. You need to find a partner, a job, all these different things. And Jung even says later in life, you have to adapt to your cultural problems and your own psyche and yourself.
So there's always constantly coming up new things that push and pull the consciousness and one into certain directions. But this still needs the participation of the person doing it. So one thing is something happening to you and you suffer for it. The other thing is whether something is then changed about the situation.
So what Carl Gustav Jung says about a complex, a neurosis, or we would also call it trauma in specific circumstances, is that this needs to be brought to light.
So this for him was what was therapy about, to take things from the unconscious, which are causing troubles and disturbances in the psyche, bringing them to light and talk about them, because this integrates them, that brings them into consciousness as they are paid attention to. This is why they come up.
These things come up from the psyche so that they get paid attention to, but at the same time, These are very uncomfortable things and we are not adapted to deal with them, so we don't want to do it. But he says, this is how the normal rhythm should be. Everybody has complexes all the time.
The question is when it becomes pathological and people cannot deal with it themselves, then an option is, for example, to go to a therapist to talk about these things, to talk them through, bring them to life, adapt to them. Bring them into consciousness and making consciousness stronger by it.
But of course, one can also suffer under neurosis and not dealing with the underlying problem. So one has a problem with the symptoms and not taking care of the root cause. And this is what he means. Just because you suffer does not necessarily mean that you will adapt automatically. This needs to be taken care of, that needs to be taken into consideration.
And a neurosis for him is even very often that people hide away from problems. So there is something that they should do, but they become more interested in completely different things and hide away from these things. Keep them in the unconscious and keep them unchanged.
So he sees there a passive and an active part about suffering, whether it is happening to one or one is, it's like a necessary byproduct of doing something. So how to recognize whether it's one or the other? For him, a big part is that on sacrifice.
And this is the second part of the of the topic for today, and I have two quotes for that. With the sacrifice, one proves that one has oneself, for sacrifice is not a letting oneself be taken, but a conscious and deliberate surrender which proves that one can dispose of oneself, that is, of the ego.
The ego thus becomes the object of moral action because the I then decides from an authority that is superior to my egohood. In a sense, I decide against my I and cease my claim to it. The second one: Despite appearances to the contrary, the establishment of order and dissolution of what has been established are at bottom beyond human control.
The secret is that only that which can destroy itself is truly alive. This has to do with most people might know it as shadow work. So Jung has this concept of shadow, which means there are things in the psyche that are in the dark and are better kept in the dark.
A little bit like in The Lion King where you have the elephant graveyard. This is not what the light touches and you should never go there. And this is where all the bad stuff are happening. Mufasa dies because he does not take care of the things that are happening in the elephant graveyard.
And Jung sees that as a willful confrontation that needs to take place, not confrontation, but engagement. So the same how Jung sees complexes as a natural phenomena and a neurosis as a healing mechanism, as a reaction of the psyche signaling, hey, here's something wrong, please pay attention.
He says this shadowy figure of the shadow, which causes Extreme emotions of hate. This is what he associates then with that, and that gets also projected on other people. This is what needs to be engaged directly and build a relationship with it.
So what Jung sees there as a necessary way of acting and existing in the psyche is building relationships with the things that are within the psyche. So when you're trapped in your apartment and there's a rabid dog that's causing trouble.
Jung says, yeah, you should try to befriend the dog, as hard as it sounds, because in the beginning this was a normal domesticated dog, but it was not taken care of, so it tries to get your attention by acting up. And this is also what children do. This is what every person does when they get ignored. They start acting up.
And he says the same thing is happening in our psyche, and we have to engage that willfully. And at the same time, this is incredibly hard to do.
Easy to say, hard to do, but a necessary thing is to have the humility to do this, to actively engage and being willing to suffer, to realize one is maladapted and one should be better and do better and follow through with that. So Jung has another very nice quote.
Which is most people don't see God because they don't look low enough. So there's a point of humility here to accept that one is limited, that one is a limited being in an unlimited universe. And the things one is doing is, are likely wrong. It's not really one's fault, but it's also one's responsibility to do then right.
And this function of engaging and relationship building within oneself. Which is pretty similar to having relationships outside with like normal people, with family, with a partner, with friends, with work colleagues, and so on. There should also be good relationships there, otherwise one is suffering.
Is the foundation on which it rests to become more adapted, to have a more complex and sophisticated consciousness. To turn into something bigger that one already is. And, and this is what I like about Jung. When Jung talks about the unconscious, on the one side, it sounds cool. On the second thought, it sounds incredibly frightening.
And then he talks about, oh, by the way, in these vast unconscious psychological spheres of forces that do not care about you because they're highly impersonal, of archetypes, of complexes, of emotions, all these different things. There's the Self, and the Self is oneself if all the things that could be integrated are integrated.
So it's future you calling out and setting oneself tasks that one is able to ideally do and content with. But this contention part is associated with suffering and sacrificing done by the person. So this all sounds very abstract.
And if we have psychological things that are common to human beings, Jung says they're codified. They're codified in culture. And we have that. We have that codified in culture, and we have it in the archetype of the hero. And this is what we also see as heroic behavior.
So when we have, for example, Firefighters. I have a friend who was a firefighter, is still a firefighter, and they had a very cool slogan. He said, we run in when everybody else runs out.
And this is this willful confrontation with complexity, with danger, in already a self-sacrificing way because they're putting themselves in harm's way. To do something, to achieve something. And this we have codified, of course, in our culture. We have it in our stories, and this is what we like to see. Like, we really want to see the story of the hero.
Can be male or female, that's not so important, but we want to see heroic behavior. And there's a very nice book by Joseph Campbell called The Hero with a Thousand Faces, which means we have there an archetype underlying that expresses itself in many, many different forms.
We know Harry Potter, we know Neo, we know a lot of movie heroes and story heroes, and they have as a similarity and as a commonality between them that they show heroic self-sacrificing behavior.
And I have quotes for that: A hero must have a large self-destructive tendency in order to be a hero. We praise the hero, and the hero contains the divine spark, or he would not be a hero. He encounters himself then as the hero and this rope dancer, but that means the marker of its own destruction.
Also, we admire and praise the hero, but he enters the mouth of the snake or dragon just because it has stared long enough at him, and he finally thinks that this is his supreme duty. So we have these incredibly old stories of people killing dragons.
We have Saint George, we have Saint Patrick, we have people confronting the monstrous to improve the life of others. Going out of the village to save the village, to fight a monster. This is an incredibly old archetypal story.
And this is what we like to see in our free time, the heroes doing heroic behavior. And there, of course, the snake, the, the, the dragon, the snake as an eternal adversary. And for Jung, this is always then an expression of psychological need.
He sees that the reason why we have myths, stories, religion, fairy tales, spirituality, and so on, even alchemy, where you have these images and stories, is because they are representing something. They talk to us. They are archetypal. They're talking to very deep structures of our psyche.
And this was his mode of operating and looking at the world. He was looking at all the products of human cultural endeavor and tries to see them through an psychological lens. He says, okay, there's a need being fulfilled and we have a need for stories.
This is why we like stories, why we spend our spare time watching a movie at the couch, but also going out to a cinema or buy a book, rent a book, or we give books to others. So that they can experience a heroic story and feel good about themselves.
The Greek, ancient Greek theater, they had this concept of catharsis where people go to theater to experience the stories there to get emotionally purged, to release emotions from their psyche that they have inside of them. Same as our body has certain needs, for example, for salt, calories, protein, all these different things. Otherwise, we feel sick. We don't feel well.
And we really like it when we consume these things. Similar, we have the need for cultural things, and stories and myths are a huge part of that. And going really back, we have a story which is incredibly archetypal for Western culture and the Western mind.
And this is also why I chose this picture for Today's event, because you saw this blue sky, but in the very, very bottom edge, you saw the cross, the Christian cross. And I have a quote for that. You never get anywhere near to individuation if you can't go through that intense mental suffering of the way of the cross.
That is another great insight into the Christian mystery and what happens when you don't confess an external Christ and an external crucifixion. It is a crucifixion that happens to you in that place where you are most sensitive, where you believe the most in yourself. There you will be crucified, and there you will undergo the worst torture.
In the mind, or in that intuition, or in the feeling of a feeling person, it is just as if the best fruit of all your attempts had to undergo the crucial pain, and that is again a repetition of the Christian mystery, but in your own psychology. So why does Jung write that? There's some words here that are important. One is individuation.
This is Jung's concept of becoming oneself, to develop, to change. And he uses the symbol of the cross for the one reason that is being used for the last 2,000 years in Western civilization.
That it needs to express something, that it is not a coincidence that it came up, and also that it's still in use, not as much in the past, but he sees there also that this describes something psychologically that needs to happen and which codified this heroic self-sacrificing behavior that was done by Jesus in in the Bible, in the story.
And the last part is also very important. Here, in the place where you're most sensitive, where you believe the most in yourself. So Jung has this concept of the superior function, which means we already have a personality.
We are already adjusted to a certain way of acting and living. And this brings us furthest. This brings us the furthest in life and in experience. But at the same time, this is the thing that at a certain point needs to die and we need to develop the other things.
So for those who are familiar with Jung's Red Book, which chronicles his own psychological journey. He had this vision of Siegfried dying. So for those who are familiar with German legends and mythology, Siegfried is a guy killing the dragon.
And he was very concerned seeing, I think, Siegfried with his skull cracked open, being drowned in a river. And he saw this psychologically wise as symbolizing to develop that meant that needed to happen in his own psyche, which means the, the most important thing that he had, which was at that point his intellect. He was an academic.
He was extremely established as that. He was a professor. He published scientific papers. He was very well regarded in not only Europe, but also in America and was friends with Freud and all these different things. It was a midpoint shift in his life that his psyche told him, oh, that's not all there is to you.
You are not only your intellect. You're missing your feeling side. You're missing your feminine side as a man. And this is what he means here, that this part in him needed to suffer and basically to die, to give then birthing grounds to something new.
And the Jung we have and the Jung we knew is because of this psychological experience of The Red Book and his elaborations on it. So he saw there certain parallels, and it is an effect that he also calls compensation.
When you run too far in one direction only, an equal weight will be generated as a counterbalance to that. These things now have then to counteract against each other to bring you back into balance. So the whole psyche is trying to make a balancing act all the time.
But this of course is not good, because, uh, at least to experience that, because we are limited beings in an unlimited, uh, universe with our limited consciousness, which is not yet sophisticated and up to the task. And we need to adapt to that, and we have to do this willfully.
And he sees that there codified in the, in the way of Christ, which is also called the Imitatio Christi. And he writes it like that: The imitation of Christ might well be understood in a deeper sense. It could be taken as a duty to realize one's deepest conviction with the same courage and the same sacrifice shown as Jesus.
And he says that this is a thing that a lot of Christians get wrong. Or let's say the understanding in the past was not completely there.
So the imitatio Christi, the imitation of Christ, does not mean like, oh yeah, you also have to be nailed on a cross for real, but rather to do and act in a self-sacrificial manner as this archetypal hero did. And he said, this is the development that people then see in their psyche if they follow through.
And he says, as I said before, these cultural products and these stories as an expression of psychology, of psychological needs. So he was super interested in alchemy, but not because he wanted to create gold out of lead, but rather he said there's telling something about the psyche. And this is what the second quote is about.
It can also be expressed in a more scientific psychological language. For example, instead of God, one can also say the unconscious. Instead of Christ, the Self. Instead of incarnation, integration of the unconscious. Instead of salvation or redemption, individuation. Instead of crucifixion and sacrificial death on the cross, realization of the four functions or wholeness.
So we, as we exist as human beings and with our psychology, it has not changed in the last hundreds of thousands years. It's just the language, how we express it is differently. And how Jung sees it in the past, this was done through mythology, fairy tales, and of course religion in a very big part.
But this, of course, has waned over the last centuries, and we kind of have lost access to that. And he sees there the reason why psychology then came up as a science, and he calls it the newest science. This was before computer science, where he says the psychology is still the same.
We might not have access as we had before to these cultural products trying to help us understand our own psychology and living our life. But we still have this need. The need is not gone. So this needs to be expressed new. And this is where he sees the reason why people now become so interested in psychology.
And he saw his life's work in digging in the past, seeing how people lived and acted there and tried to express their psychology to find the modern language, which can now be understood by modern people. And this language is psychology.
And when I read this, I had to agree with him on a large part because it feels right now everybody is interested in psychology. Everybody wants to understand. People want to understand how they work. They want to understand how other people work. They want to know how they can improve themselves.
And we have now a pretty sophisticated system, let's say, where we describe these things. But Jung says the psychology that's underlying is the same. It's expressed in a different way.
This is why he translates it into that, which doesn't mean that we are all secretly Christians, maybe, but rather that our psychological needs are the same and they still need to be felt and understood. And this is pretty clear when, when the normal condition is like you exist, so you suffer, but it's just already also a Buddhist understanding.
There needs to be some reason in there. There needs to be some higher purpose in there that it's not only suffering. And this is where I found Jung deeply, deeply optimistic in saying that, oh yeah, it's looking bad now. But actually, that's a positive thing.
This is a point in time where it's possible to grow and develop, and this is also how things are supposed to be. Life is not only sunshine and roses. It should be, of course, be from time to time, but be happy when it's the case. But otherwise, there will be problems. But at the same time, this is how it's supposed to be.
This is how it's supposed You are supposed to become what you are. It has to go through this very dark valley. It has to go through the dark night of the soul. And this is what we have in stories where there is this moment where everything seems lost.
And this dark night of the soul is also used by Joseph Campbell, who was a huge admirer of Jung, and describes when the hero is at the lowest point, when they do not know what to do anymore. If you, for example, stay with The Matrix, Neo has been told he's not the one, he will not save humanity, and the only guy who believed in him, Morpheus, has been captured by Agent Smith.
And nobody engages with agents because they always lose. So what does Neo do? He goes anyways to save Morpheus, to confront the agents, and He is even to put up a fight with them. Of course, that is still not enough.
He gets shot, but he gets then resurrected through being kissed by Trinity, which is funny and sounds now very Christian, but this, it's just the Hero with a Thousand Faces is trying to capture that archetypal story and find it in more other stories, not only Western, but also worldwide stories.
And is this then willful confrontation with difficulty, suffering through it and being willing to sacrifice oneself psychologically, please psychologically, and being humble enough to accept that one is limited and getting in this then very dark point from there, something new is possible.
And this will be what a follow-up event will be about, because that's resurrection and rebirth, because we cannot only end this at the lowest point. But these two topics of suffering and sacrifice, I really wanted to talk about, and I wanted to talk about what Jung understood under it and how it's an integral part of development.
Because when you, for example, look into self-help, you don't find that so often. Self-help is very often very positive, like just think about what you want to have and then it will manifest. But it's not, oh yeah, suffer horribly, but become a better person at the end. And this is what I like about Jung.
And this is why it will be a follow-up event about this, because of course Jung talked a lot about the other side, which is resurrection and rebirth, mirroring, of course, the archetypal story of, of Christ. But The event will be about so much more. Good.
But I want to thank you for your attention and suffering with me, and I hope you learned something, and I hope you had fun in this joyous topic. And yeah, now I'm very interested in the discussion part. Thank you.